on this friday night
unwavering uncertainty in china
michael spafford's trial ends without a
verdict
what's canada's next move it took a long
time in ottawa to understand that common
sense would not work
ontario's troubling trend younger
patients with covid
in intensive care two unlikely allies
team up to get a child killer into a
maximum security prison they've totally
left victims out in the shadows a global
news exclusive
and back on the front lines you can
retire
but you can never stop being a nurse the
remedy for a health care crunch
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
for two tortuous years michael spavor
and michael kaufrik have been held in
jail in china
today spavor appeared in a chinese
courtroom on charges of spying
but there was no decision and the prime
minister has tough words
for the closed door proceedings their
arbitrary detention is completely
unacceptable
as is the lack of transparency around
these court proceedings
the chinese government fired back
pointing to the case of mangwon joe
arguing the cfo of huawei has been
arbitrarily detained in vancouver
abigail beeman has our top story tonight
starting in 10 minutes and we don't have
access yet tense moments ahead of
michael spavworth's trial
news cameras pushed away diplomats kept
out
after two years behind bars the
espionage trial lasted
two hours with no verdict yet remains
unclear what is transpired in the
courtroom
and we remain frustrated about that
close to a dozen
international allies were there and
apparently spavor caught a glimpse of
their support
he saw us the lawyers in a harshly
worded statement from the chinese
embassy canada is labeled hypocritical
and
arrogant and the canadian claim the
cases lack transparency
is called quote fact distorting the
prime minister disagrees
it is disappointing that the trial
undergoing that michael spaver went
through and
possibly the trial that michael kovrig
will go through on monday
is happening in secret without
transparency without access
justin trudeau says china needs to
understand it's not just about two
canadians but about its relationship
with other countries too
the trial coincides with the first
meeting between the biden administration
and china
in alaska i am very confident that this
is an issue that will be raised
one former canadian ambassador to china
says rallying international support has
been the only part of canada's strategy
that's worked it took a long time in
ottawa to understand that
common sense would not work in fact i
think that ottawa should have adopted a
much firmer tone right from the outset
should also have taken measures to
retaliate against
china the family of michael spavor
describes him as an
ordinary businessman who has done
extraordinary things to build ties
between canada
china and korea now they await a verdict
as the family of michael kovrig awaits
his trial
scheduled for monday in beijing abigail
beeman global news
ottawa trudeau expects the fate of the
two michaels to come up today during
high-level talks between china and the
u.s this is the bad administration's
first sit-down meeting with chinese
diplomats
and as jennifer johnson explains their
relationship is off to a frosty start
well in frigid alaska
heated exchanges between top diplomats
from the biden administration and china
in their first face-to-face meeting both
sides took aim over the coronavirus
cyber attacks unfair trade and human
rights abuses
we got a defensive response
but we were also able to have a very
candid
conversation on iran on
north korea on afghanistan on climate
the chinese are warning the us to stay
out of its internal affairs
they said the u.s doesn't represent
international opinions
and criticized america's own human
rights issues
including the quote slaughter of african
americans
the biden administration slapped new
sanctions on china the day before the
meeting
quickly dispelling concerns it won't be
as tough on china as former president
donald trump
i'm very proud of the secretary of state
u.s secretary of state anthony blinken
just met with japan and south korea's
leaders who also expressed concerns
about china's heavy-handed tactics on
activists and dissidents
there are a number of areas where we are
fundamentally uh
at odds including uh china's actions in
xinjiang
with regard to hong kong tibet
increasingly taiwan
expectations were low for this meeting
but the white house describes it
as a starting point after decades of
tense relations between the world's two
superpowers jennifer johnson global news
washington it's a big weekend for the
country's official opposition
more than 3 000 conservative delegates
are taking part in a virtual convention
they've been debating policy and
strategy to gear up for a potential
federal election
this year but there are signs of
frustration some members
aren't keen on the direction of the
party our chief political correspondent
david aiken is keeping an eye on the
convention and david it looks like erin
o'toole has his work cut out for him
well that's right robin and o'toole just
gave a speech at this convention where
he looks to get past all that grumbling
it was a speech where the objective was
not just to unite conservatives
but also to appeal to the broader
general electorate
to those who may not have voted
conservatives since stephen harper won
his only majority 10 years ago
we must present new ideas not make the
same arguments hoping
that maybe this time more canadians will
come around
to our position if we are to have a
general election this spring
this may be the first campaign speech
the conservative leader
pitching for support he'll need to
defeat justin trudeau
the conservative party can defeat him
but only with the courage to grow
and that's the key message find those
voters who have not voted conservative
in more than a decade
there are still many missing details to
o'toole's plan but
he sketched out some broad strokes
including what the conservatives call
their
canada recovery plan we are the party
that will ensure canada has a real plan
for reopening
and rebuilding our economy a real plan
to get life back to normal he also
promised a more credible plan
for climate change in the environment
but details will come later
though he did vow an o'toole government
would repeal
the trudeau government's carbon tax we
will scrap
justin trudeau's carbon tax on working
canadians
he also promised there will be
consequences for mps
like prime minister justin trudeau who
break conflict of interest laws
multiple times we will toughen the
conflict of interest act
and the lobbying act and impose higher
penalties to end abuse by liberal
insiders
now going into this weekend's convention
we have multiple polls showing
conservative support
has been softening dropping under 30
percent
so conservatives are hoping that
o'toole's campaign speech this evening
begins to reverse that trend robin david
aiken and ottawa thanks david
canada's top doctor says an increase in
the more transmissible kova 19 variants
is threatening the progress being made
by vaccines
new daily cases across canada rose by 8
percent over the past week
at least 4 500 variant cases have now
been confirmed
in some parts of the country they make
up most of the new cases
at this point team variant has the
ability to take off fast
this is a crucial moment if we don't
slow down the spread of the variance
team vaccine is at risk of falling
behind
health authorities believe the variance
could be behind a recent uptick in
severe cases across the country
as eric sorenson reports there is a
concerning shift
in who's at risk almost 10 percent of
canadians have now received a first
shot but vaccines are playing catch-up
covet variants are amplifying the
pandemic
and another curveball younger adults are
getting hit harder than
expected ontario has seen a spate of
cases as the variants
spread we are seeing that the variants
of concern are
are striking more younger people
if the variants of concern
increase exponentially we're going to
need to have
medicine beds we're going to need to
have more intensive care beds more
ventilators
but we're ready for that readiness
includes a field hospital outside one
health center in toronto
if a third wave takes hold
hospitalizations in ontario rose
dramatically in early january
fell just as rapidly until mid-february
now the numbers have begun to climb
and the need for intensive care beds
also peaked in january then dropped off
but have risen again to more than 300
icu beds now in use
and it's not just older patients who
need them says one er physician
that's really what we're feeling right
now is patients in their 40s to 60s
who are sick with covid whose oxygen
saturations
are low who need to be admitted and some
of whom need to be admitted to the icu
one explanation for a growing number of
serious cases among younger adults
older canadians are increasingly
protected by vaccines
if you have less older people being
susceptible because they're vaccinating
you have
a larger proportion of healthy working
people
younger people being exposed in any
event covid variants are throwing a
wrench into plans to normalize life in
this country
until vaccines in bigger numbers can
come to the rescue
the vaccine i think would contribute to
decelerating the epidemic but
it's not going to do it yet the public
health advice for now
social distance a while longer and that
includes saying no
to big gatherings at easter eric
sorensen global news toronto
and there are fears those variants could
fuel a third wave of infections in first
nations communities
so the military is being called and to
get more shots into arms
my department and the canadian armed
forces will begin
supporting an unparalleled accelerated
vaccination program in a number of
isolated first nation communities
as well as a select number of larger
indigenous communities starting in
manitoba
the initial deployment will include up
to 23 different communities
in northern manitoba two unlikely allies
are joining forces coming up in a global
news exclusive
their mission to move a murderer back to
maximum security
plus rodents running rampant when mice
aren't so nice
these critters will give you the jitters
a mice plague is running rampant in
rural australia infesting
just about everything from crops to
kitchen cupboards
a bumper harvest is serving as a buffet
for these mice and hay bales being
stored for winter have been destroyed
the rodents even got into hospitals and
bit at least three patients
experts say the population of these
pests boomed
after unusually heavy summer rains
the story of torrey stafford is one
canadians will never forget
the eight-year-old from woodstock
ontario was murdered by michael rafferty
and terri lynn mcclintock
in april of 2009. torrey's killers have
both been moved to lower security
facilities over the course of their
sentences
and learning of each transfer is painful
for torrey's family
rodney stafford torrey's father has
found a surprising
ally in his fight to get his daughter's
killer into a maximum security prison
mark carcasol explains convicted
in the killing of eight-year-old torrey
stafford michael rafferty is serving a
life sentence with no chance of parole
for 25 years
he's currently at a medium security
facility in quebec
rodney stafford torey's father says he
was not informed till
months after rafferty was transferred
out of a maximum security facility
and they've totally left victims out in
the shadows the public safety minister
at the time
insisted rafferty's new facility
specializes in dealing with sex
offenders but that didn't sit well with
rodney
speaking on condition of anonymity a
relative of rafferty stepped forward to
try to help get rafferty back into
maximum security
claiming the convicted killer had been
extorting money from his mother he had
been reaching out to his mother
on a regular basis and sort of um
you know getting money uh sent to him
and sent to uh what seems to be inmates
spouses claiming that
he was fearful of his life that
he had old people this relative does not
believe rafferty was really in constant
danger in prison but that he was just
manipulating his mom to help pay other
prisoners back
allegedly for things as basic as junk
food from the canteen
he provided us with a folder filled with
copies of checks and money order
receipts
to people mostly in quebec but as far
away as bc
rafferty's mom lived in ontario who are
these people
i i honestly don't know who they are
we've got boxes
and boxes of them but there's probably
the equivalent of
thirty thousand dollars worth of money
that is sent through
to other people out there just here so
this isn't even it that's not all of it
no
we contacted several of the people
listed on those documents none would
corroborate this relative's claims
we reached out to rafferty he also
refused comment
rafferty's relative says the family
repeatedly asked corrections canada to
stop rafferty's calls to no avail
and that he emailed back and forth with
officials for most of 2019
sending them details and copies of those
receipts and
we have yet to hear anything further
from that
corrections canada tells global news it
does review information about inmates
brought to their attention from both
victims and families
but that's citing the privacy act it
can't comment on rafferty's case
michael rafferty's mother deborah murphy
died of a heart attack in 2018 at the
age of 60.
this relative holds rafferty personally
responsible the stress
of the constant phone calls and
the struggle financially to try and keep
supporting
him in prison was just too much for her
rafferty's relative hopes sharing their
story will reopen the conversation about
rafferty's move to medium security
in solidarity with tory stafford's
family to know that his family
is willing to make those steps as well
to
do what's right in this case it's i
couldn't i couldn't appreciate it
anymore
mark carcassel global news toronto
barriers to vaccination still ahead the
essential workers who
may not get their shots
you're watching global national
one of the most important tools to
protect people against kova 19
is the vaccine as provinces ramp up
their rollouts advocates are raising
concerns about some essential workers
being excluded
because of their immigration status
there are about 1.6 million migrants
refugees
and undocumented people in canada many
of them are in industries at high risk
of exposure working long hours
with low pay but as christa hessie
reports
they're facing huge barriers to get
vaccinated
lily has risked her life working on the
front lines in one of the most dangerous
settings for covet 19 deaths in the
country
long-term care homes she should have
been one of the first people to receive
the vaccine
we are on the front lines every day like
everybody else and still we are being
bored
still in january lily's employer sent an
email asking staff for their provincial
health card in order to get it
something she does not have we're not
using her real name
she's undocumented and she fears she
could be deported
it's something that plays on your mind
every single day that you could be found
out
despite assurances from federal and
provincial governments that the vaccine
will be available to everyone
regardless of status advocates say the
reality on the ground is quite different
even though provinces have laws
governing consent and the sharing of
health data
for undocumented people the fear of
personal information being shared with
border services
and possible deportation is too great
karen koch from the migrant rights
network says they're already seeing
people struggle with access
so unless those concrete measures are
taken to ensure
in practice that everyone has access the
policy won't matter
this deeply ingrained fear could mean
the half a million undocumented people
in canada
don't receive vaccines if you don't
treat
everyone in your community and it's a
pandemic
you treat no one everyone is at risk
global news reached out to the
ministries of health in ontario british
columbia and quebec
provinces that have large numbers of
migrants and undocumented people
all provinces said a health card will
not be required to get the vaccine
but they do require information such as
a full name date of birth and address
that level of identification would keep
them away the migrant rights network
says granting people permanent status
would solve a lot of these problems
permanent residency is what's going to
give people access to the same rights
and protections as everybody else
colford says he's frustrated by the lack
of action from the federal government
after all these years they still
continue
to let these people fend for themselves
and be lost
christa hessie global news tomorrow on
the new reality
krista will take a deeper look at the
medical volunteers trying to provide
care for undocumented patients
turned away from hospital or told to pay
for treatment
that's saturday night at 7 pm right here
on global
up next the canadians putting retirement
on hold to help out
on the front lines
some canadians are putting retirement on
pause to join the fight against coven
19.
thousands of doctors nurses and other
health professionals have already spent
long careers
caring for the sick and will now serve
as critical reinforcements
for canada's mass immunization effort
karen lieberman shares their stories
as vaccine supply ramps up across the
country the number of vaccination
clinics is growing i do need permission
to give you this vaccine can i have your
consent
please heeding the call to help you can
retire but you can never stop being a
nurse
a not so fresh crop of health
professionals
rejoining the workforce
45 years in nursing was not enough for
lorraine gonzalez
she now spends 12 hours a day at this
vaccine clinic
i just felt that i had something more to
give so when they said
can you come back and vaccinate i
thought yes
returning as a reinforcement on the
front line was a no-brainer for this
general surgeon
it's extremely satisfying particularly
the patient population we're dealing
with now in the over 80s
these are remarkable people even though
he only
just retired three months ago it didn't
work out so well did it
no last spring the registered nurses
association of ontario reached out to
past
members we acted right away with the
nurse and we got i think
over 10 000 nurses not all retired
that were willing to go to icu to
vaccinations to do to
case and contact tracing you name it you
still got to wash your hands
jane cornelius a former icu manager has
come out of retirement
twice in april they asked me to come
back and help
and then i went back into retirement
because things settled down
and now with vaccination they've asked
us to come back and help
common among these retirees is their
eagerness to pitch in
people needed help and that's what
family doctors do is they jump in there
and help whenever help is needed
the way out of this pandemic she says is
to get everybody vaccinated
until then retirement is put on pause
i'm hoping by september that i'm flying
off somewhere nice and warm
time on the golf course the the things
you should be doing when you're retired
karen lieberman global news toronto
and that is global national for this
friday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is a view of the
portman bridge from coquitlam bc
we'd love to see your corner of this
country so please keep sending your
photos
to viewers at globalnational.com thank
you for watching and i'll see you back
here tomorrow have a great night